je crois qu'on va passer un très bon
moment je vais vous laisser méditer
cette petite phrase le côté obscur de la
force redoutez vous devez
voilà la pop dance c'est fini oubliée la
bonne entente dans la fratrie pogba
depuis que mathias veut ternir l'image
de son petit frère paul et si ce dernier
dénonce les tentatives d'extorsion le
web lui s'en amuse car mathias affirme
que l'international français aurait fait
appel à un marabout pour ensorceler
kylie ann papé et amoindrir ses
performances sur le terrain on peut
parler de l'entourage de deux grands
joueurs du passé ce soit platini que ce
soit zidane que ce soit didier deschamps
jamais il ya eu une embrouille jamais
jamais jamais parce qu'ils sont
structurées et parce que ils ont un
socle familial qui est extrêmement
solide là vous vous rendez compte pol
pot bois que vous connaissez qui est
vraiment un mec bien il est complètement
dépassé dans cette situation
[Musique]
la musique c'est du bruit qui pensent
à qui on doit ça à victor hugo ou abouba
[Musique]
abouba non
à bogota en colombie regardez c'est un
concert géant ça ce passe en plein air
s'est présenté comme le plus grand
concert au monde figurez-vous seize
mille artistes au total ce sont des
jeunes musiciens issus des écoles et des
orchestres de la ville
d'où jouer pour la paix et pour la
mémoire de leur pays les écoutes
niveau style honoré sony possède ni
fausse blonde n'est posée mais bosser
alors comment est ce assez fine couche
épouse
[Musique]
j'ai dit mettez vous là
étaient tous là il vient de me dire
est-ce que je pour lever mon masque
banon
je sais déjà qui est le génial le petit
jeu des ressemblances là on a pensé à
johnny hallyday mon vous le fais souvent
pendant la présidentielle on vous disait
que vous aviez d une ressemblance avec
fabien roussel ça n'arrêtait pas ce
costume noir bah si les yeux bleus quoi
ou alors les yeux bleus cheveux
grisonnants sayed dans le mois le nombre
de gens que je vois je croise alors on
me dit que je suis votre saisie
des fois c'est flatteur il ya des fois
ça elle n'est pas vraiment vous n'allez
pas me parler du sexe à des escalopes
quand même je sais que certains font le
buzz là dessus c'est pas mon sujet pour
moi on mange de la viande en fonction de
ce que l'on a dans le porte-monnaie et
pas de second mandat dans sa culotte ou
dans son slip lorsque 82% des sommes
espagnols change de sous vêtements
quotidiennement suivis des italiens 77%
les français sont les derniers du
classement avec 73% pire encore un homme
sur cinq ne change de caleçons que deux
fois par semaine les femmes relève la
note de la france et 93% change de
culotte tous les jours la moyenne
européenne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
wolfe pas connecté dansokho la map ou
connaissent très bien
il me parle il discutait avec moi il n'a
pas compris le principe il parle avec
moi c'était en décembre 2021 l'humanoïde
baptisé à mai qu'a dévoilé dans une
vidéo sa surprenante ressemblance avec
nous autres les êtres humains depuis il
n'ya eu le csa las vegas où les
visiteurs ont pu approcher ce robot
développé par une start up britannique
huit mois plus tard à mecha a fait des
progrès aussi impressionnant que
troublant il reproduit en temps réel nos
expressions faciales hills
[Musique]
est-ce que les robots vous contrôlez le
monde à la fameuse question je pense pas
je pense que vu que c'est à partir du
moment où c'est nous qui il est vrai
mais il ya un moment le robot il va se
retourner contre nous il va dire tu t'es
c'est le scénario de beaucoup de films
en tout cas oui j'ai regardé troll est
non mais je continue
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui tu as raison
mais aussi qu'est-ce que oui est-ce que
ça ça vous flatte quand tout d'un coup
on vous a dit que vous ressembliez à
brad pitt qui faisait la une de check
your browser
non parce qu'au début on va parler ce
truc là je roule à rouler j'ai vu la
photo on est libre maintenant c'est brad
pitt mort je ressens à brad pitt quand
il est très très très moche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ça je vais si on l'avait pas vu
moi